Sergeant correa's mother Madeleine frame
says Bragg's decision has re-traumatized
her and she joins me now Madeline I'm so
sorry for your loss uh one of your son's
attackers was out of jail just 14 months
after going to jail so what's your
message tonight to Alvin Bragg
thank you for having me
my message to Alvin Bragg
is to I would like to see him one time
just once go down to the morgue with one
of the mothers of a homicide victim when
she has to identify her child's body
and see how traumatized and how
heartbroken and how dishearted that
mother is and then to have to fight with
the criminal justice system to try to
get Justice for the people who killed
her child and then he turns around
and treats the the killer like they are
the victim and the victim like they are
the Killer
this is what I've been experiencing for
four years this started before Alvin
Bragg it started with Cyrus Vance Alvin
Brad came in and completely dropped the
ball on the case
completely dropped it Madeleine Bragg's
office
um they're responding to criticism about
this issue of lowered sentences saying
it's false data it's the comparison that
doesn't take into account the challenges
of Discovery or the impact that covid
had in our city in fact as we prosecuted
459 more felonies this year compared to
last we have three times as many gun
convictions so far as of all as in all
of 2019 does that give you
any relief here or
does that make you feel any better given
what's happened to you and your family
no because I know the inside story about
what's happening in the Manhattan
Criminal Court
homicide cases haven't been tried since
2015. they're currently working their
way forward and they're only up to 2018.
this is why those charges those murder
charges those murder cases are being
dismissed to try to clear the calendar
from the backlog
are you surprised that New York ended up
voting for Kathy hokel given the fact
that she's pretty much lent her support
to Alvin Bragg throughout this entire
uh period of deep pain for the people of
New York over this crime problem not
only am I surprised them very very
disappointed very disappointed
because
the definition of insanity is doing the
same thing over and over again expecting
different results
she said with her own mouth
that she doesn't even acknowledge that
crime is a problem she said to lead Liz
Alden during the debate she doesn't
understand why crime is so important to
him so she's someone who doesn't even
acknowledge that it's the problems
it's unbelievable Madeline your your
strength and your passion uh is
inspiring and we're going to continue to
pray for you and your family thank you
for joining us tonight we really really
appreciate it hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else